buildings roads and bridges all rely on
materials such as concrete and steel but
the construction sector is responsible
for 11
of humankind's co2 emissions
that's about the same as russia and
india's combined share of emissions
could alternative materials like bamboo
wood or even mushrooms help this
industry go green
oliver morton senior editor and one of
the economist climate experts answers
your questions
why is the construction industry so bad
for the environment
there's a whole bunch of reasons one is
that most of the materials that you use
in construction
have energy embedded in them it has
taken energy to make them there's
another thing which is that you know
there's actually a lot of energy
involved in moving things around also
construction is a very very
decentralized industry buildings are
made by all sorts of people all sort of
like trying to get along and it's not
the sort of industry that you can move
quickly towards a new sort of like
environmentalism just by telling a few
people what's what why isn't concrete
sustainable and how can it be improved
the thing about concrete is the concrete
little bits of rock and cement that
sticks them together and the way that
you make cement or the clinker the
cement that uh people currently use in
uh concrete is by taking limestone and
effectively heating it so much that the
carbon dioxide in the limestone
limestone being calcium carbonate
gets out of the limestone so it's
intrinsic that you produce carbon
dioxide that's a big problem because the
world uses a lot of cement so you've got
three options you can either make it
more cleanly use less of it or take away
the pollution straight away there are
various startup companies and non not
just startups looking at alternative
cements to put into concrete so
non-carbon dioxide producing cement
what are the most promising alternatives
to traditional building materials
well in an odd way some of the most
promising alternatives are other
traditional building materials and you
know you might think of wood and bamboo
um also quarried stone can be used in
various ways that tends to be expensive
but there are other things like waste
plastic um in theory some metals uh if
you make it with um renewable energy
aluminium is an interesting building
material i think
wood really has um a huge amount going
for it all materials have energy
embodied in them the energy embodied in
wood is pure sunlight wood can be pretty
much fireproof these days and um it's
got incredible mechanical properties
people are looking at building
skyscrapers out of wood the problem is
that wood is quite expensive and it's
recently become far far more expensive
lumber prices have shot up over the last
six months so in theory i can imagine a
lot more use of wood but you have to be
careful with sort of like sourcing and
regulation to make sure that you're
using wood that wouldn't be better left
as a tree can mushrooms really be used
to construct buildings
i love this question um for various
reasons one of which was a little while
ago i was uh i i was one of the
coaches i suppose for a team of
synthetic biologists um at
stanford university and brown university
um who were looking at exactly making
bricks out of mycelium out of mushroom
stuff
for habitat on mars and one of the
reasons why this is more practical than
it sounds it's not practical don't get
me wrong is that mars has low gravity
and the biggest problem with mycelium
with mushroom as a building material is
that it doesn't take compression loads
very well so you can't put much weight
on it and so that's that's something you
don't mind about so much when the rest
of your building is also light because
you're on mars on earth it's a bit of a
problem so my suspicion is you know for
load bearing i would feel worried about
uh mycelium but for other things it
might be used to make a very good um
insulation
how can buildings be designed to be more
sustainable
the best way to make a building
sustainable is to give it a lived life
of decades or ideally centuries um
and
for that i think flexibility is really
important so one thing about design is
not to enforce too much about how the
building is used in its primary design
design is always in everything a
trade-off and there are ways to make
things sustainable that aren't
necessarily ways that you would that you
would actually get people to
particularly want to live in one example
is that
since it's now so cheap to make light
through leds and
the electricity leds can be made
renewably there's an argument the
building that a sustainable building now
basically needs no windows
but getting people to choose to live in
houses that are half buried in the
ground because that's good for thermal
insulation and have no windows some
people would make that design choice but
others would not
so you'll always have to trade things
off but so if i had one wish it would be
flexibility
can sustainable materials meet the
demand from emerging economies
not at the moment no i mean the demand
for better accommodation in emerging
economies is huge and as yet there's
very i mean if the construction end
industry is disparate um and partially
informal in developed countries all the
more so in developing ones so to
actually meet those needs through with
sustainable um approaches really will be
very hard i think the thing that
governments can do and this applies
particularly to the american to
governments in america but also
elsewhere
is
make it easier to build big buildings
that house lots of people where people
want to live putting people into quite
dense accommodation in places where they
want to live is a really good way of
producing fewer greenhouse gases in
construction and we talked earlier about
traditional building materials and a
better use of modern design a better
modern designed use of traditional
materials including particularly wood
and bamboo that might definitely be a
help
but at the moment i think it's going to
be easier to make
developed country construction greener
than developing country construction
thanks very much for watching for more
of our coverage of climate and
sustainability please click on the link
and don't forget to subscribe
you